how's it going honey  Eddie hot dog you did such a good job  time can use your props  my dad is Mike he works on a drilling  rig the pond so we allow from underneath  ears and we're the Explorers like you  are like Dora that oil is a monster like  the mean old dinosaurs all that it used  to be so for 300 million years these old  dinosaurs have been getting squeezed  tighter then dad and his friends make a  hole in their roof these mean old  dinosaurs can't believe it  bring it up so they rush to the new hole  then smack they run into this stuff  called mud they cram down the straw pull  just down we build the maneuvers that  was a 10-4 ever please  none you need to give me a fossil oh  yeah I will I want to be able to hold it  up and say my data cams the dinosaurs  my peculiarities if I show you the rest  you have to promise not to run away